votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
alors il ça vous êtes le roi de l'impro
j'essaie vraiment très large bande et
merde ça va on a produit ce qu'on veut
faire
on va essayer de voir si même avec les
plus mauvais vous êtes bon d'impro ainsi
pas avoir un bon partenaire en impro oui
eh bien on vous avez faire trois scènes
trois scènes avec des situations
différentes
vous allez en faire une avec bernard
montiel une avec gilles verdez et une
troisième avec enora attention bon vous
retournez vous vous retournez vous vous
retournez par là y'a rien compris
mondial 1 vous vous retournez par là et
dès que vous voyez le thème apparaître
vous vous retournez vous nous faites une
petite à près de 30 secondes d'accord
attention c'est parti ici à bernard
montiel qu'est ce qui se passe pour ça
vous découvrez que vous êtes jumeaux
attention vous vous retournez rêvait
j'en rêvais mais c'est pas croyant je
t'ai cherché sa fait 20ans mais ça fait
30 ans que moi je cherche et l'aja n'est
qu'à 22 ou amusants des 30 de plus en
réalité rien compris dans les 22 0 au
tour et maman comment elle va bien elle
est morte
moubarak
le deuxième thème coup de foudre pendant
une boum alors pu tâter gaulle et tu
feras chin vivrait sirois [ __ ] aime
les gens comme moi au cinéma avec toi ma
chérie qu'est ce qui se passe ainsi de
voeux
moi aussi je t'aime alors attention à
faire trop réel personne n'était pas ma
cour jeudi
[Applaudissements]
et c'est visible mourad houas luna oui
regardez la situation est coincé dans
l'ascenseur avec un problème d'haleine
attention mais tu as oui
[Rires]
[Musique]
tous les vaccins sont drôlement fort ici
à un peu à peu à un moment on voudrait
créer assez détaillée à la nav
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ça joue bien qu'on retrouve aux feux
de la rampe à paris la vie dorée musique
des feux de l'amour
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qu'on essaierait au fond de
cette beauté
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]